hey everybody it's Gary vaynerchuk and
this is a very special episode of the
askgaryvee show featuring The be friends
yo hey Gary should people be worried
about losing their jobs to AI oh alien
you're going right for the jugular look
I know this is a huge conversation but a
capital alien what you do so well is
exactly what I want everybody here to do
well AI is going to enhance a lot of
your jobs not eliminate them we've seen
this through the last hundred years of
Technology people fear things when they
first hear about it without realizing
all the consequences all the critical
thinkers all the creative set are going
to be more creative and more critical
thinking because they're going to be
able to get the commodity of actually
typing it out done for them but the big
stuff is still going to be any you know
that big head of yours and outdoor alien
you're gonna be able to use it more with
AI that hurts and the reality is that
some jobs will be affected by that but
back to being adaptable maybe this is a
cue for those people to go get jobs that
they actually love right on how about
actually using this moment of AI
infringing on your space to go do
something you love that's adaptability
that's not hearing change that's
realizing change is real it's always
been here this put a lot of people out
of jobs sure did pissed it yeah you know
everything does Uber did yep seamless
dead yep Amazon did yep social media did
we're very scared by this because it's a
hair different than what we've seen
before but it's really the same you're
in control of your adaptability be an
alien and go make yourself happier be
adaptable
it's